[Music]
big personalities millions of social
media followers TV appearances and a
large paycheck some kids found the way
to break free from the regular kid life
and do something most of us can only
dream about don't forget to hit that
notification bell to never miss another
video and be sure to check out our
community section for even more fun if
you like crafts and DIYs check out our
friends at crafty hackers they have this
awesome video about ways you can recycle
regular objects into toys they'll show
you how to turn your useless everyday
items into amazing kits toys make sure
you check them out and be sure to leave
them a like click in the corner to watch
now here are the 10 kids who figured out
how to make millions
Thompson aka the one and only honey
booboo child in case you're not familiar
with her story Alana Thompson first
appeared on a controversial show called
toddlers and tiaras and her antics
instantly grabbed the attention of the
Internet
school affection and opana honey boo boo
is most known for her sassy attitude and
her hilarious one-liners although Alana
is no longer doing reality shows her
family made millions and it was all
thanks to her sassy personality it's
been reported that Alana made up to
$20,000 per episode
however some statements also say that
later seasons brought in a check of
fifty thousand dollars per episode
either way it's safe to say that this
honey boo boo child definitely rocked
our worlds and we all loved tuning in in
2018 Alana is still sharing words of
wisdom by clapping back at ignorant her
life seems to be much more chill
nowadays but we're all waiting to see
what this attitude fool diva will do
next Maddie Ziegler Maddie Ziegler
started her career on a hit TV series
Dance Moms known for its controversial
teaching approach and endless drama with
the so called momma Gers but after
endless hours in the dance studio
Maddie's passion for dancing finally got
her recognized by SIA who put her in a
chandelier video and the rest is history
Maddie's impressive net worth is
reportedly as
at 2.5 million dollars as of 2018
Maddie's earnings reportedly comes from
the actual Dance Moms episodes where she
allegedly made $2,000 per episode with
almost 200 episodes on the show this
pretty much adds up to half a million
dollars throw in Co videos SIA concerts
TV appearances merchandise movie roles
and the book and she definitely showed
that with hard work and passion you're
really able to get what you want and her
dancing inspires people around the world
to top it off Maddie won two Teen Choice
Awards in a row as a favorite choice
dancer how cool is that
Mackenzie Ziegler but if we talk about
Maddie we also have to talk about her
little sister Mackenzie who's two years
younger than her sister often left in
the shadows of her sister success on
Dance Moms Mackenzie had trouble finding
her own identity back when she was a
dancing machine but that dilemma was
over when Abby Lee Miller discovered she
can sing known as magazine back then
Mackenzie released a self-titled album
which made it to number one of the
iTunes charts and continued releasing
songs long after the Ziegler's parted
ways with Abby Lee Miller both Maddie
and Mackenzie also started a fashion
line and just like her sister Mackenzie
had plenty of TV appearances her
estimated net worth stands at around two
million dollars which is pretty
impressive for such a young teen and
although Mackenzie is no longer
following in Maddie's footsteps she's
definitely marching to the beat of her
own drum
or better yet singing to it her songs
have millions of views as do her videos
on the App musically it's safe to say
this one definitely figured out how to
make millions
even after Dance Moms evan tube HD can
you make millions off of reviewing toys
yep you can you might be familiar with
evan tube if you're into hilarious
review toys Evan the charismatic child
it totally steals the show he really
knows how to work that camera and his
reactions are absolutely adorable the
YouTube channel has billions of views
and more than 5 million subscribers
that's pretty amazing for a six-year-old
that reviews toys right the channel was
soon making enough money to pay for
Evans college costs as well as rack up
some pretty amazing sponsorships it's
been confirmed by a family member that
Evans channel makes around 1.3 million
dollars annually which means that Evan
is much more than a millionaire the
family states that the channel opened a
lot of doors to them and allowed them to
do some pretty remarkable things they
also had the opportunity to work with
the make-a-wish Foundation after a young
boy's wish was to meet Evan and make a
video with him at Legoland the kid is
not only a millionaire he's also able to
change lives with his YouTube channel
so grab your cameras have an opinion and
start making videos jacob sutorius it
really seems like the internet is
opening so many doors for talented kids
doesn't it you're probably already
familiar with Jacob sutorius but did you
know that he's a millionaire the kids
really do know how to become popular
themselves and make money with their
popularity and talent that's exactly
what happened to Jacob who released a
viral single called sweat shirt back in
2016 since then Jacob has had four tours
and eight more singles his singing
career really took off and so did his
bank balance and 28 teen has been
reported that Jacobs net worth is
actually 1 million dollars so this
talented teenager actually just became a
millionaire Jacob actually had it quite
difficult upbringing and was also
frequently bullied for his love for
musicals but he's definitely the one
that has the last laugh even though he's
still just a teenager his career is
already pretty successful and we have a
feeling this is definitely not the last
we'll hear from this talented kid do you
think Jacob will become the next Justin
Bieber come let us know in the comments
I catch you outside what does that mean
Danielle Bragg Olli yep Danielle Virgo
Lee is officially a millionaire this
sassy red had really caught everyone
outside when she showed them she's not
just in it for those 15 minutes of fame
on dr. Phil instead cash me outside girl
took her career pretty seriously she
appeared on dr. Phil at the age of 14
and managed to accumulate 1 million
dollars in the next year by becoming a
viral sensation along with pretty much
becoming an instant viral meme Danielle
is also serious about making music she
adopted a new nickname called bad
under which she's releasing hit after
hit her YouTube channel has almost 5
million subscribers and most of her
music videos have way more than 10
million views Danielle seems to be
making quite a name for herself she's
also collaborating with well-known
artists such as ty dolla sign although
many people started out with having a
negative opinion on this viral sensation
it's safe to say that this is not the
last time we'll hear from the cache me
outside girl and we absolutely can't
wait for more music Millie Bobby Brown
although as of June 2018 it seems that
the Twitterverse decided to pick on this
wonderful actress her bank account stays
unbothered Millie Bobby Brown is just a
teen but she's already one of the most
talked-about actresses in the world you
might know her from stranger things
where she stole everyone's hearts with
her amazing acting skills she reportedly
earned $30,000 per an episode of
stranger things and her reported net
worth stands at about three million
dollars Millie's Instagram following
stands at an impressive almost 7 million
followers and each of her pictures has
millions of likes that's pretty amazing
for a teenage actress Millie's also an
ambassador for brands such as The Sims
and people frequently enjoy her antics
through her Instagram videos Lilly is
also known for having a unique fashion
style and her outfits are frequently
featured on fashion magazines and
although she's most known for her role
of 11 on stranger things we have a
feeling her acting repertoire will only
go up it's safe to say she really did
figure out how to make millions by doing
what she loves and by being herself
baby Arial here's another viral
sensation that started her career on the
app musically it's absolutely incredible
that a teenager can make a lip-syncing
videos on an app and ends up becoming
one of the most popular teenagers on the
planet but her original reason behind
making music please is quite painful
according to Business Insider baby
Ariel's family was going through a tough
time and in order to distract herself by
what's happening around her she turned
to musically she started making music
leads every single day and people
quickly noticed her efforts and her
charisma she now has millions of
followers and a net worth estimated at
almost
two million dollars that's pretty
impressive for someone who was just
lip-syncing to music she became a
social-media influencer and signed to
the CAA talent agency she also has a
YouTube channel with three million
subscribers recently she also released a
new song called Gucci on my body which
was very well received as were her
previous songs Arielle is barely
seventeen but her future seems
incredibly bright we have a feeling this
social-media influencer will continue to
keep herself and her fans happy with her
work Annie and Haley LeBlanc and then
there's everyone's favorite sister duo
that just seems completely unstoppable
if you're a youtube fan there's a good
chance you've probably heard of Forte
lay before the main stars of the channel
are Annie and Haley LeBlanc from showing
their gymnastics talents to hanging out
with the coolest crowd getting
sponsorships having their own music and
starring in several TV shows both Annie
and Haley leblanc are keeping busy Frito
Lays estimated net worth stands at 4.2
million dollars the girls also starred
in a youtube series called chicken girls
and made several other appearances the
Internet Movie Database also lists Annie
as an actress and an executive producer
of a youtube series called a girl named
Joe Annie also won an award for the
Muser of the year as she accumulated an
impressive amount of followers on the
app musically isn't it crazy how much
her life can change when you start
uploading daily YouTube videos
Jojo Siva let's talk about one of the
most viral TV personas ever you might
remember
Little Miss Jojo with the Bobo from
shows like Abby's ultimate dance
competition and later Dance Moms where
she starred along Maddie and Mackenzie
Ziegler she immediately became a fan
favorite after people noticed her
ridiculously large hair bows but small
dance studios were just a bit too small
for this diva with an attitude and she
soon discovered ways to build her own
empire JoJo's personality attracts
millions of fans who tuned in to listen
to her music and watch her shenanigans
on YouTube her line of accessories which
includes her hair bows became an instant
hit and absolutely everyone started
wearing a bow in their head but how much
does dojo earn from all of this some
websites are reporting that her net
worth stands
1 million dollars others say it's 8
million dollars but whatever the number
it's safe to say that Jojo Siva is
indeed a millionaire but we're pretty
sure her bank balance will only improve
because in 2017 Nickelodeon officially
signed Jojo to an overall talent Dyl
which means we'll be seeing this beau
wearing deva pretty much everywhere
who's your fav teen influencer at the
moment let us know in the comments
thanks for watching and we'll see you in
the next video
[Music]